so hört es sich an wenn wirklichkeit und
politik aufeinander treffen
mal die warnung die halben tag vorher
waren schon verstehen ist ein
riesengroßer versagen wir werden keine
wahl merken müssen sie leider auch dass
du später in flammen
eine woche im schlamm gelebt also das
war die geballte wut nach der flut die
da armin laschet dem unions
kanzlerkandidaten gestern in seine
heimat direkt bei ihm vor der haustür
entgegengeschlagen ist im flut
krisengebiet in heimerzheim im
rhein-sieg-kreis heftig wurde armin
laschet an die mangel genommen bei uns
im studio ins bild chef julian reichelt
wenn die politik auf so viel wut trifft
nach ja zwei wochen nach dieser
flugkatastrophe dann muss sich daher was
aufgestaut haben dann musste was vorher
gewaltig schief gelaufen sein
da hat sich ganz gewaltig wasser
aufgestaut wir haben in den letzten
wochen hier bei bild live immer wieder
darüber berichtet was da im vorgang
alles schief gegangen ist wenn über 100
menschen tot sind dann muss etwas schief
gelaufen sein
das ist die wut die sich da jetzt
entladen hat gegen angelastet und wir
sehen noch etwas interessantes ich
glaube alle kanzlerkandidat nicht nur
armin laschet armin laschet olaf scholz
aber auch annalena baerbock wollten uns
einen eher schläfrigen wahlkampf
präsentieren indem sie uns vortragen was
so ihre idee sind regina wir nicht und
wir sehen jetzt der wähler will das
nicht der wähler will über die themen
sprechen die ihn bewegen die nur
anderthalb jahre bewegt haben corona die
ihn seit fünf jahren bewegen die
flüchtlingsfrage aber auch über die
themen die ihnen in den letzten wochen
bewegt und ihn hab und gut und manche
menschen sogar das leben gekostet haben
darüber will gesprochen werden darüber
wollen die menschen sprechen und wir
haben gestern eindrucksvoll gesehen dass
es ganz schwer wird wer sich diesen
emotionen im wahlkampf zu ziehen und die
menschen so einzuschläfern wie angela
merkel deswegen ihren wahlkämpfen
erfolgreich die menschen die wollen
antworten haben die wollen jetzt
politiker haben die entschlossen
durchgreifen die lösungen präsentieren
die den menschen jetzt in den
flutgebieten auch ganz konkret helfen
lass uns noch mal reinschauen ganz genau
wie diese emotion sich gestern an
laschet entladen hat zwei tage später
hat man ihnen verlacht weil nichts
passiert sind
wo war diesmal die warnung die halben
tag vorher
mit europa wir sehen amila sitzt
ziemlich unter bedrängnis da teilweise
waren bis zu 100 menschen um ihn herum
zu fällen versammelt und sie wollten
antworten antworten auf ihre probleme
auf ihre not derzeit bei uns im studio
bild chef julian reichelt denkt glaubst
du dass das krisen-management jetzt auch
seine kanzler kann schafft verzeihung
wirklich gefährden könnte
also wir sehen im moment ein ganz
interessantes phänomen armin laschet hat
schwierigkeiten in einer situation einer
naturkatastrophe einer flutkatastrophe
die normalerweise so zynisch wie das
klingen mag eigentlich eher die stunde
der regierenden ist ja die stunde wir
erinnern uns an gerd schröder der mit
einer flut situation eine sehr knappe
wahl um die entscheidenden null komma
irgendwas prozentpunkte gedreht hat
normalerweise sind solche krisen die
stunde der exekutive wo man auftreten
kann stärke zeigen kann helfen kann vor
ort sein kann
empathie zeigen kann armin laschet hat
damit seit beginn dieser krise seit
diesem jahr an den wir uns alle erinnern
und an die sich auch viele wähler noch
erinnern seine probleme und strauchelt
im moment ein bisschen durch die
flutgebiete das was wir da eben gesehen
haben da muss man vielleicht einmal zur
einordnung sagen das ist natürlich auch
eine undankbare situation aber ich
glaube sie steht für etwas größeres und
eben nicht nur für die flut die sich
dort ereignet hat sie steht dafür und
das wird ein riesiges wahlkampfthema
dass zu viele menschen in diesem land
das gefühl haben dass verantwortlichkeit
für krisen katastrophen und fehler fehlt
in der politik wann hat es den letzten
rücktritt in diesem land gegeben ich
erinnere mich an unsere
bundespräsidenten christian wulff ich
erinnere mich an karl theodor zu
guttenberg das waren die letzten großen
rücktritte in diesem land seitdem egal
was passiert ist hat es in diesem land
keine übernahme von politischer
verantwortung mehr gegeben und das ist
das was menschen sich erwarten wenn wir
uns an den g20-gipfel erinnernder hat in
hamburg die stadt gebrannt während die
politik in der äpfel haben und die
freude schöner götterfunken gehört hat
und dazu so die finger bewegt hat ist
dafür jemand zurückgetreten nein das war
das karrieresprungbrett für urlaub stolz
zum vizekanzler und jetzt zum kanzler
erkennen wir erinnern an unseren
terroranschläge und wir erinnern uns
jetzt an das was dort vor wenigen wochen
passiert ist und inzwischen ist es so
dass der gedanke dass dafür jemand
verantwortung übernehmen sollte der in
führungsverantwortung war von der
politik als geradezu obszöne abgetan
wird
medien werden dafür angegangen wenn sie
wenn sie fragen wer übernimmt denn dafür
die verantwortung der katastrophe
deutschlands höchster
katastrophenschützer der inzwischen sagt
es gibt eigentlich gar nicht den
höchsten katastrophenschützer in
deutschland war im urlaub als diese
warnmeldung eine nach der anderen ein
liefen als das wasser immer weiter stieg
und ist auch nicht etwa aus dem urlaub
zurück gekommen sondern erzählt uns
jetzt oder hat uns dann erzählt dass
viele leute sich einfach nicht an die
regeln gehalten haben die innenminister
in den beiden betroffenen ländern nrw
und rheinland pfalz die in der
vergangenheit gute arbeit gemacht haben
aber in der situation eben nicht spielen
nicht mal mit dem gedanken verantwortung
zu übernehmen für das versagen dort vor
ort landräte haben wir da einen
rücktritt gesehen nein keinen einzigen
menschen fragen sich einfach warum sind
die politiker die ich wähle eigentlich
immer nur verantwortlich wenn es gut
läuft aber nicht wenn eine solche
katastrophe untersucht und letzter punkt
wir haben hier schon oft darüber
gesprochen das thema soforthilfe
soforthilfe funktioniert dann wenn ich
als ministerpräsident oder als landrat
oder als innenminister überprüfe und
überwache wie jemand das geld in einen
koffer packt und damit in die betroffene
region fährt um es dann an die leute zu
verteilen und ihn vor ort zu helfen und
wir haben einen interessanten satz viele
interessante sätze darin gehört aber mit
armin laschet der den menschen sagt wir
werden milliarden akquirieren
ja das ist eine sprache die menschen die
im wahrsten sinne des wortes bis zur
hüfte im schlamm stehen nicht verstehen
sie wollen nicht dass jemand milliarden
akquiriert und wisst ihr warum weil sie
ja die milliarden vorher bezahlt haben
das sind ja steuergelder und es gibt
eine situation und das ist so eine
situation in der ich erwartet dass mein
start den ich bezahle und die politiker
die ich wähle die bei mir geworben haben
die ich auch bezahle mir einmal
tatsächlich helfen indem sie mit dem
geldkoffer kommt
und das ist wenn mein haus weg ist und
wenn wir dann jemand erzählt er will
milliarden akquirieren dann ist das
nicht das was ich in der situation
brauche sondern ich brauche 2000 5000
euro auf die hand damit ich irgendwie
wieder im wahrsten sinne des wortes
boden unter den füßen bekommen und wir
sehen bei dieser veranstaltung ganz klar
diese menschen haben erstens große wut
und zweitens sie haben keinen boden
unter den füßen
und noch was zeigen meiner ansicht nach
diese bilder die wir gesehen haben auch
während du gesprochen hast julian du
sagst du einmal die differenz zwischen
der sprache auf der einen seite von
armin laschet und der sprache der bürger
mein eindruck ist nie in diesem moment
gestern gewesen dass da menschen mit
menschen sprechen sondern eben ein
ministerpräsident ein politiker ein
regierender mit den menschen warum spürt
man in solchen momenten wahnsinnige
barriere zwischen diesen zwischen diesem
jahr offenbar verschiedenen welten
ich glaube die antwort ist weil es
inzwischen verschiedene welten sind und
das zeigt sich im moment an der flut auf
ganz extreme weise aber das was wir in
den letzten jahren erlebt haben es hat
nicht nur mit der flut zu tun
es gibt tatsächlich eine entkoppelung
zwischen den menschen dirigiert werden
und den menschen dirigieren das merken
wir in den medien das merken wir auf
wahlkampfveranstaltungen wo sich dann
auf einmal wenn die wähler mal mit den
regierenden in kontakten auf einmal
diese enorme wut endet das merken wir
auch in der sprache ja was was mich
verwundert und man muss noch einmal
sagen undankbare situation für armin
laschet aber davon wird es noch viele
geben im wahlkampf und der bundeskanzler
in diesem land werden da muss man sich
unter gefahrensituationen stellen und
dann muss ich eben auch das wird
schwierigeres kommt muss man das kommt
man muss sich den den emotionen der
menschen stellen haben wir in dieser
zugegeben undankbaren situation den
einen moment gesehen in dem man das
gefühl hat ich bin euch nach
ich bin bei euch ich verstehe euch wo es
die schaufel zeig mir dein wohnzimmer
einer sagt aber zu den beerdigungen
kommt ihr welche beerdigung was ist
ihnen widerfahren einer ein mann
berichtet dass nicht gewarnt worden ist
nicht gewarnt worden das muss man
einfach sagen und es ist bisher auch
noch nicht klar wer dafür verantwortlich
war dass nicht gewarnt worden ist und
das ist auch vollkommen klar dass in der
politik niemand so wirklich interessiert
ist an der frage und anderen zu
beantworten wer dafür verantwortlich war
da kommt ein mann und sagte es ist nicht
gewarnt worden und wenn ich meine eltern
nicht nachts um zwei raus geklingelt
hätte während die tod ja da muss ich ja
hingehen zu diesem zu dieser person und
frank erzählen sie mir von ihren eltern
erzählen mir von ihrem schicksal
erzählen sie mir was ich tun kann
es bringt nichts dann zu sagen wir
wollen hier ein problem lösen
die leute stehen tatsächlich vor dem
nichts teilweise ohne verwandten ohne
haus da geht es sich um wir werden ein
problem lösen und milliarden akquirieren
sondern was ist ihre geschichte und wie
kann ich bei ihnen sein
wir sind bild und wir liefern dir deine
news auf youtube zum nächsten video
kommst du hier
und vergiss bitte nicht unseren kanal zu
abonnieren